par jean les chanteurs français
l'attendaient pour l'ethiopie mais vous
n'avez pas été aussi nombreux qu il
qu'il le désire et hier à la courneuve
pour le fameux concert puisque on estime
qu'il y avait à peu près vingt mille
personnes alors que les chanteurs
français en attendaient à peu près 100 à
150 milles en fait il voulait envoyer un
milliard de centimes à l'ethiopie ils
seront contraints d'envoyer un petit peu
moins comment vous expliquez georges
moustaki subit d'un petit peu des
chanteurs français à la courneuve et
vous y étiez vous aussi - les
organisations non non pas du tout je
crois que c'est le prix des places qui
étaient réverb athée parce que pour une
chose assez populaire où on peut aimer
même le chanteur très fort on va le voir
que pour 3 minutes au four 10 minutes
je veux dire il fallait pas traiter ça
comme un spectacle c'était comme un
rassemblement et détruire un peu
d'ailleurs chi des prix voyez les prix
étaient 220 français moi je quand je les
sujets étaient déjà très pessimiste je
crois que vous avez pas le sentiment
d'avoir fait un coup pour rien si je
vous dire moi je n'ai pas fait grand
chose je suis arrivé un peu la dernière
minute mais ce n'est jamais pour rien
d'abord c'est ça donne une information
et qui est nécessaire et puis où il ya
quelquefois des revers dans notre
travail de notre de nos actions mais ce
n'est pas ça qui est décourageant si
c'est dommage mais parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde et c'est la première
fois que j'ai rencontré autant de deux
confrères ce même espace as était
réjouissant vous aviez déjà participé à
d'autres manifestations de ce genre pour
des organisations humanitaires
je me vois que je fais partie des coûts
des vétérans qu'ils font ça depuis très
longtemps c'est pour ça que hier j'ai
regardé un peu la nouvelle vague le
faire avec des moyens très importants
mais justement c'était là le prix des
places qui ai un peu pensé les choses et
demain soir vous serez à la maison de la
mutualité avec des moyens moins
important apparemment des prix
d'ailleurs qui sont moins élevés puisque
je vois qu'ils sont de 75 francs vous
allez participer à un concert aussi avec
d'autres chanteurs
pour les mexicains je voudrais dire que
bon moi je suis un de ces chanteurs qui
qui travaillent en voyageant ou qui
voyageront travaillons et je suis parmi
origines nos enfants du tiers-monde et
le mexique fait partie d'un de mes pays
par sa jeune entouré que par des gens
des laïcs latine dont un grand ami et
une grande personnalité qui atahualpa
yupanqui qui se produit très peu et je
crois que ça vaut la peine d'aller
écouter certaines très grand poète
gauche aussi un guitariste ex chaleur
c'est à quelle heure demain soir c'est à
21h la salle de 9 mutualité je donne
l'adresse parce qu'ils sont scellées
golding enfin c'est rue saint-victor et
c'est au métro maubert
merci georges moustaki nous avons eu
beaucoup de plaisir à vous avoir parmi
nous et à antenne 2 me